yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing my way and what is he doing here
actually yeah I had this fake I record
this yeah there are lines here that I
good for a while but think some c3 stuff
is good this song wow he just loses a
move there why is that good this has
been very comparable to the pain
variation B 595 but Queen chief for now
is attacking III mmm tricky business out
let them cannot just develop them it's
not a try for a refutation which is
probably existing somewhere I don't
believe in this black line okay anyway
um what's going on here just e6 yeah if
I move it away yeah maybe maybe maybe I
can just go away with the night yeah if
you wonder if i'm living near church i
do I mean it's not like the the house
step directly nearby but the bells are
always pretty pretty loud our d 5 he can
play near five the sound estimated when
I played night to you too he pretty much
has to play t5 know ok this is this is a
good a good alternative
and now I can't go there still concerned
about this Bishop somehow doesn't seem
to be very very unconventional position
and now we always opens it up okay and
isn't this kind of loose so C 3 not so
much maybe a three and then Knight c3
yeah maybe this one maybe just play
sephora or something in this typical
tricky style that he has them yeah I'm
not so happy with this but what can you
do I didn't see it correctly that he has
you for okay so what's going on here in
this position he has weakened his King
side quite a bit
ok so here be five he's going to take on
see to whom what to do let's take it
yeah so b5 rook takes Queen e2 I don't
know that looks very loose again like
there are some tactics I don't know well
maybe it will be one for a pin yeah only
one but then that the queen is not
actually hanging it is protected by the
bishop ok getting somewhere little
slowly but so hook takes ok doesn't take
it but here isn't d for simple move it's
also be six potentially and let's keep
this when we keep the pawn it also gives
me a couple of good job squares so he
wants to take them I'm happy with this
if he takes on b3 let's do this
the time situation is more of an issue
and lights it to actually I've look f5
I've got rookie five
yeah maybe he just takes it takes b6
naval tb6 but ok it is often coming up
with the orphan plays very surprising
moves here my way we should see form
will tick you have to play ok let's see
to a five-time morning what a messy
position so he's attacking this and but
I can't play and play the night yeah the
time will be at the biggest problem
position the position I don't understand
simply I simply don't understand the
position so Knight b6 SN the idea
Wow don't get them don't I cannot handle
this way there with no time kind of try
to simplify it a little bit make it
easier to play check check draw me not
bad for white at all but still tricky
it's not so desirable to trader will
clear it I'm kind of try to play play
simple stuff yeah Kim now I will lose
this on time very stupid from a very
good position probably position so
pretty dead
draw offered draw author draw offer
which one having wrong he's a nice guy
doesn't want to doesn't want to play
this on time yeah okay yeah so very
difficult as usual I can probably start
an alliance really early here with stuff
this is very weird maybe nine of 60 I
just recognize that this was a possible
at him does it seem to be also clear
though check check check check well
there's a funny line equally i would
actually expect me where top p.m. first
impression i thought why should be worse
wow ok um yeah and here you want to play
five but maybe this is good he always
has those tricky lines that are that are
that are interesting d sexy i probably
not the greatest solution to go to you
too i was expecting them to play d5 here
and thought is equal which is probably
roughly true yeah
yeah that I thought should be good for
me but he always has those tricky ideas
before so here here 93 takes young and I
should be substantially better but it's
not so easy to prove in the long run
let's see five was good yeah but what
such happens after this I takes b7 ok
and then 96 ok ok this is the thing I
didn't think about this one that got
crazy quickly yeah and surprisingly it's
good for good for white but I am down to
40 seconds per ship since seven was
doing it yeah I was really trying to
play simple so that I can actually make
some quick moves and in the process i'm
giving up can't by step to the win cut I
mean here white can never lose ready but
did this kind of approach with root g3
is not trying not trying to win maybe g4
but he's probably coordinated enough now
so this was directly going through the
draw I think I can take h6 now which I
missed I'm kind of curious and so the
engine is on minus one year doesn't
recognize that it's a complete draw I
think it is a complete draw the only
winning idea i would see is like going
here and then a tech g2 with an idea for
at the end of such a procedure now it's
lets the draw position
it is this a draw okay interesting game
again as it always this against my way
thanks for watching